In this problem, we are concerned with two types of energy, kinetic energy and potential energy.
Kinetic energy is due to the speed that is the length of the velocity vector
and it grows with speed in a quadratic fashion.
It contains a factor of the velocity vector of the spacecraft, length of that vector squared,
meaning if increased the velocity by a vector of two, we are going to increase the kinetic energy
by a vector of four, which tells us that speeding is really dangerous.
There was another factor in here, the mass of the spacecraft
and then there is an additional vector of one-half.
Potential energy concerns the position of the spacecraft.
As we move the spacecraft away from earth, we have to invest energy
and that's going to become potential energy.
This is the distance of the spacecraft from the center of the earth.
When you fire the rockets to get it away from earth, you invest energy
and that energy leads to a change in potential energy.
In the case of gravity, it's easiest to have potential energy be negative all of the time
and only when the spacecraft reaches infinity, it's potential energy go to zero.
And the formula for that is pretty much related to Newton's universal law of gravity.
We've got the gravitational constant. We've got the product of the masses.
Mass of the earth, mass of the spacecraft, and in this case, divided by the first power of the distance.
If you remember in the force, we have the second power of the distance.
And of course, we have the minus sign in front if we double the distance, we go to half that original value
but still with the minus sign and these are the only kinds of energy in our problem
and if energy conservation holds, we know the following.
The sum of these two energies has to be a constant. It must not depend on time.
It has to stay at its initial value and that's something we can use to check our numerical solutions
when this expression does not stay yet its original value, we do know that we're in trouble.
Note that energy conservation does not hold in all models.
In particular, if we have friction and all the heat produced by that friction,
energy won't be conserved.